houston I understand you attended law
school I did okay and when you came to
LA was your focus to become an attorney
no it actually wasn't that was the the
main reason I came to LA is so I
wouldn't become an attorney and I went
to law school in Virginia and at a great
law school and I really loved the
experience and did really well my focus
was on entertainment law and litigation
at the same University where I went to
law school there was a film school as
well and so naturally given the the
subject matter of my study which was
film law and entertainment law I became
friends with a number of film students
at the same University started writing
and producing content on the side of law
school and all the spare time you have
in law school and then just kind of got
bit by the bug and really started to
drill down in that last semester of law
school you know what exactly do I want
to do with the rest of my life is it you
know cuz I'm very much a you know I want
to I want to pursue work that doesn't
feel like work and if I could you know
money was no option I could do anything
I wanted to do would it be going into
the law office every day it's gonna be
in going to a courtroom every day and it
wasn't that I was more attractive to the
other side of the transaction on the
entertainment side of things so luckily
the the Juris Doctor degree is very
versatile and so I knew I could use it
to pursue entertainment as a producer as
an agent as whatever I wanted to do when
I got out here and you know at least
that's what I told my mother-in-law so
as though it wasn't a big waste of time
but but yeah so so once I graduated law
school in Virginia pursued a couple
opportunities there but we really made
the decision to to really move out here
so we ten years ago just packed up our
Jetta sold everything we had and just
came out here so and been here ever
since has been great
you